a yaf speaker was just
had to just be escorted out of a speech
at the university of buffalo
by the police the yaf chairman
this young student called the police
while cowering in the bathroom from the
violent mob the violent mob was made up
of blm members
blm members who showed up to the
university of buffalo and didn't just
politely ask their questions but we're
threatening people we're getting very
very violent we're banging very heavily
on the doors and the funniest part of
all
you know who the speaker was
alan west
not not a white supremacist last time i
checked alan west very much a black man
who has very mainstream conservative
political views he was giving a talk on
how america is not a racist country this
was too much for blm so they chased all
these people off campus and and what
what they believe what the leftist at
you buffalo and blm specifically
believes is that if they make enough of
these threats and they have enough
people escorted out by police and they
have enough students cowering in the
bathroom calling 9-1-1 that
conservatives are going to stop showing
up to campus
and so yeah they'll get they'll get in
trouble maybe some of them will get in
trouble actually probably probably they
won't given the left-wing leadings of
the universities but hey they'll achieve
what they wanted which is to kick
conservatives off campus sort of immoral
means but they're going to get that end
that they really want so they think it's
all justified i am scheduled to speak at
the university of buffalo
in two weeks i believe
and i suspect they think that they're
going to get my speech shut down because
oh we don't want to hear it probably the
university administration doesn't want
to have to deal with this probably
there's going to be a lot more security
costs
and they think that we're just going to
say okay we're not going to do it maybe
we'll go next semester
but you know me
you know i'm i'm not going to give in
that easily so i will be going to
university of buffalo i can't wait to
give my talk on yaf i think i'm going to
focus in particular on how blm is a
criminal organization
and how we're not going to put up with
that we're not going to be bullied and
we're not going to back down and we're
not going to let the radical left take
over our entire country
because we don't want them to chase us
or threaten us with physical violence so
i'm going to go there and i think i
think maybe they just gave me my topic
for the speech i very much look forward
to that if you're in the buffalo area i
sure hope you come out you can find out
more at yaf.org sign up get some tickets
it's gonna be a lot of fun
gonna be a lot of fun they're not
they're not gonna take away our fun i
don't think so i'm glad you like that
clip now
ring the bell subscribe get those
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you